Hôm năm gần đây thôi đó, đặc biến họ ngọt thằng mạnh, để nó hoài quý nó sức nó, nó sẽ chỉ trọng thôi,
để trên dẻ mạnh quá, thêm họ chưa mình khữ không, thế thì mình cảm giác như thế này, và lúc mà nó trọng thể quý còn thức khác,
cho cũng khẩy, mấy tháng, ở giờ nó mới ra được cái sóng như thế này.
Sợ đúng cảnh nó luôn đặc nó từ đây nên xuống, cái có nước mà mình trọng thông bị nét và ăn sẽ không bị ngán.
Sởi vì chắn rất là ai thị,
nhưng không có cái ai trong mình ngãi nóng,
ai phải là tình thầy.
Đói đó mà không xuất nữ chỗ khác,
vô đại là nót tôi,
có bà mấy lắm nè.
Cô họt cho,
có sự truyết,
có điều là hơi rất sợ bức khọt phần quên,
nhưng mà đối với mình mạnh mở hình thế là vô.
Em ăn,
hơi đây là tự lúc,
mất cái trường,
tôn tôi,
nó nữ lệ rối ở trong,
hắn chắn đây là nóng,
nóng nóng nóng.
Dạ,
dống như nóng,
vui nhật,
Ok, nhưng mà hả thậm nè tiếp quề không phải yên đầu mình cũng ra rất nhiều khó cảnh thuộc này
Đó bán cũng tới từ phố kia tổ tổ khác hợp tàn Họ phó vảy
Hãy dào thì hảy hội mình bán người trong bình tầm phải hai mai trăm tô mỗi ngày
Một phần bất dành giáo đầu tổ và mua yên cho tới xáu huyện